all right sir you all ready for some
positivity
[Music]
[Applause]
what oh my gosh what's up
yo kelly as you yes what's up are you my
surprise
look like you're doing a show or
something i'm supposed to be getting my
poker game on with josh groban and you
know get to the bag
what's going on wait what no this is no
this is you've just zoomed my show this
is the kelly clarks show you know
this is my show oh no you know you know
i got love for you but i think i'm on
the wrong
zoom oh okay well you should drop by for
music week but that's fine that's
totally cool um
i wasn't in invited to a poker game
that's totally fine
um but while you're here like i'm just
saying could you maybe give us
a major key for season two inspiration i
mean you're here we're here why not
oh kelly you know i got love for you um
the major key
is to make sure they watch the kelly
clarkson show
because it's going to put a smile on
your face and that's the major
you learn yes i love that major team
i'll get you the right number for josh
groban it's fine
finish your show but i love you all
right all right bye dj khaled
my kids love lemonade that's their
favorite thing is lemonade
perfect i can't give it to him too much
but i have this big freaking tree at the
new house we're in
you have a lemon tree
[Music]
[Applause]
hello we can't hear you you can't hear
me
now we can are you my surprise no i'm i
mean
why am i seeing you guys i'm supposed to
be hooking into josh groban's poker
party are you part of the party
wait what what no no but i like poker
hey i'm sorry to see that you're not
going because i would have really
enjoyed taking some of that sexiest man
alive money off of john
i think it's funny he thought i got
money for that
oh my gosh well okay well you've got to
come on the show at some point i'm sorry
i'll get you the right number okay
okay i sure like to do that first of all
good luck for the next season
and john just do me a favor don't get in
on the sexiest man alive
[Applause]
we didn't get invited to a poker game
whatever but first
everyone knows john's wife kristy teigen
is the cook in the family
she's got books people and
oh my gosh nellie are you it's nelly
are you are you my surprise nelly i love
you
oh wow this is dope i didn't know you
guys were playing in the poker game
today
oh my god you've got to be kidding me
this poker game
first of all i'm really upset that we
weren't invited and secondly
it's the wrong number do you have
josh's number i hate to ask you but okay
great
yeah no i mean i wasn't invited but i'll
get you the number it's totally cool i'm
not offended
uh-huh nelly everybody appreciate it
you got it good job natalie
welcome back everybody it's music week
and what better way to kick it off than
with the
oh i'm just growing or you know what
don't
you're not my surprise you have a
freaking poker game going
on i know listen uh kelly i call i just
called in
to apologize mainly because i
gave all my friends your zoom room
instead of my zoom room by accident
and i apologize for the inconvenience
and it will not
it will not happen again but i just
wanted to call in and not only say sorry
but to say that you know i think it's
great
you're doing music week because music is
helping all of us
get through these crazy crazy times and
uh so thank you for that and again i'm
very very sorry yeah no that's real
sweet and all um when were you gonna say
sorry for not inviting me to your poker
game just curious just waiting for that
one yeah
is it just no room you should you should
check your junk folder
i think it's probably in there you're so
full of it groban
no i'm just kidding i love you so much i
gave the right number to everyone don't
worry about it
um it is great to see you um you've got
to come back soon we love you here
i would love that kelly and and you are
always welcome to any virtual poker game
anytime you seem a little busy right now
though but love to you and love to
everybody stay safe
with groban but whatever bye josh
i love groven although i kind of had to
self-invite myself it's fine
um it's not the first time people
you